he is the head coach of the Rams as I
said Shaun McVeigh how are you
coach I'm doing good are you doing right
Tom I'm out ain't no I don't think I'm
ate like a yearly thing man that I was
on with you last year we had our bye
around Halloween time and that's right
you know you got to get me on around
Halloween I like that now you were going
to a party for Halloween for your bye
week are you are you dressing up as
anybody today you know it worked out
where we had a little bit of time off
but right the only thing I'll be doing
is trying to figure out how we're gonna
go try to be the best we can against a
tough team this weekend okay in in the
saints let's let's jump into a couple of
items is Cooper cup gonna be on that
field in New Orleans do you think I
think so rich you know he's he's done a
great job you know Cooper he's attacked
his rehab the right way and you know
looking forward to seeing him on the
practice field this week but you know
he's he's feeling good he's very
optimistic about it and you know the
anticipation is that we will ask him but
I think it's been great you know we've
obviously missed Cooper a lot but I
thought it's also given guys a chance to
step up and I think we've seen Josh
Reynolds do some really good things to
continue to add to the depth of our you
know our offensive receiving core but
the work site about getting Cooper back
and unless there's a setback we're
expecting him to go and how much do we
see Dante Fowler Jr the player that the
Rams less need front-office acquired for
you and Wade Phillips in your defense
just yesterday yeah and I was a great
job by lesson his staff targeting it and
being able to get it done and you know
we actually Dante is in right now
getting his physical everything checks
out you know being able to get him as
far as you know quickly as we can get
him up to speed you know we'll be how
much we're able to utilize him but but
we're expecting him to be ready to go
this weekend and looking forward to get
him going in a Rams uniform okay so
let's talk about last week's game did
you think Todd Gurley was gonna score at
the end of that game coach you know what
I didn't because Todd is a situational
master rich and he knew exactly what to
do right there and you know he is he's a
special player but he's also one of the
smartest players I've been around and I
think that his big picture understanding
and most importantly just the
unselfishness that he demonstrated right
there when you look at just the
production he's had specific
touchdowns and always putting the team
in front of some of the individual
things you can accomplish I think says
as much about Todd and really our team
as anything when one of our captains our
leaders is doing the little things the
right way and try to find ways to just
win the game even if sometimes it does
hurt your fantasy that he's not on my
team coach okay he's not on my team so
just want to let you know that was not a
personal question it is something that
everybody is talking about and so is
that something that you've discussed
with Todd or you or it goes unsaid you
don't have to remind him of situation
you know as coaches it's our job to try
to create clarity but our players know
that you know we're in constant
communication with them we knew going
into that situation right there that if
we were fortunate to get a first down it
was one of those deals where it's a
first down go down we don't want to end
up scorned because we don't ever want to
get the ball back in number 12 hands for
the opposing team and we can just run
that clock out and ensure the victory
Shaun McVeigh Rams head coach here on
the Rich Eisen show how much better can
Jared golf get what are you working on
with him day in day out coach you know I
think it's just the consistency at what
you play with I mean you look at guys
that have been doing it for a long time
whether it's Aaron Rodgers Drew Brees
this weekend you're talking about a guy
like Tom Brady I mean these guys are
masters of the position but there's
always that continuous improvement that
focus on excellence with regards to
different defensive structures timing
rhythm the mechanics of the way that you
consistently want to deliver the
football so there's so much to that
quarterback position entails but the
thing that's great about him rich is
that he's obviously so talented but he's
got a great feel for the game and as
he's continuing to accumulate these
experiences you know you almost just put
them in your inventory of your memories
so that you can say Raa this is what
Green Bay and Mike Pettine gave me this
is what a Gus Bradley gave me and you
know these are things that you know I've
played against the Dennis Allen led
defense last year and those experiences
serve as great reference points for you
just to continue to accumulate mental
reps and then be able to use them to
have success on the field now obviously
with all due respect to Wade who's the
guy love that
as you know we've had conversations
about what you know you don't like you
know I don't know that I've ever met
anybody you know if you meet somebody
say you know I don't like Wade Phillips
and I think the problem is probably with
them it's a new problem that's it's not
a me problem it's a new problem when it
comes like that so but with due respect
to him and that defense that is building
and building we just mentioned Dante
Fowler it could come down to the ability
of you and Jared golf communicating and
executing on offense because of the way
that Brees and Peyton are executing on
offense on the other side is that's
something you think about coming into
this week knowing that you've got a play
caller and a quarterback combination of
the first variety on the other side
their coach yeah you know I think what
we talked about is we have a lot of
respect for just what a complete team
the Saints are in all three phases and
what we try to do every single week is
figure out okay what's it going to take
you know for all three phases to play
complimentary football and really you
know these eight games that we've had up
to this point have served as great
reference points for us you know we're
defense has had a handful of big
conflation crunch time to be able to win
games offenses had to do some things to
close it out obviously special teams the
other day you know Aaron gets a big stop
when we're down one point end up going
and kicking a field goal and then to be
able to allow repeat Wilson then to make
that play so I think it's been about all
three phases but certainly we always
have to be ready you know with
contingency plans based on the way that
the feel the flow of the game plays out
and you know from an offensive
standpoint we want to try to be as
efficient as possible and move the ball
and score points but it's going to be a
great challenge at New Orleans
especially against the defense that's
playing as well as they have of late
then your first year and a half as head
coach in the in the National Football
League if you had to change from one
rule you could waive the Sean McVeigh
wand you could change a rule what would
that be I mean what are we talking about
specific to what I mean what do you mean
that what don't you like I mean you're
like you know what I wish this got
changed is it a defensive penalty rule
is it an offensive rule is it something
but more challenging and think about
that you know I think one of the things
that's kind of come up that would be
helpful especially once you get later on
in the year just with regards to
injuries and different things like that
just being able to you know up that
active gameday Ross or just go sometimes
you get into situations where guys are
having to play with positions you know
where sometimes you've seen some lineman
go down and you end up having to have
tight ends playing tackle you know
fortunately that hasn't happened for us
but I would just say increasing the
active roster but I mean if I sat down
and thought about it I mean I'm sure
there's always things but the thing
that's good about the league is they're
always working towards just you know
collaborating with you know the the
league the worker coaches work with the
Players Association to try to figure out
what's best you know for everybody
involved in how can we continue to make
this a great product that people love
the watch I took you out of your tunnel
vision on the Saints right there just
that one glory did I took it right out
of it okay I just want to make sure that
I just was asking because I'm curious
still got it
all right coach I know you're you're
going from meeting to meeting I
appreciate you jumping out and on the
phone for a bit well chat soon okay
sounds good thanks rich I appreciate you
having me on you bet anytime at a place
Sean McVeigh the reigning coach of the
year in the National Football League the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience